welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day five and
we're gonna learn the meditation and
mindfulness habits of billionaires
enjoy
[Music]
usually before the sun comes up i offer
myself
to something greater than myself
if it's for one minute 20 seconds or 10
minutes
i at least stop in that space in my
house every morning
i have a little meditation space where i
just go
i have beautiful spiritual readings
there i
light my three candles there daily word
or
something and i express to this greater
energy field than i
that i don't want to be alone as i move
out into the world
for me at this particular time in my
life i recognize that everything is
about
moving closer to that which is
god and without a full
spiritual center and i'm not talking
about religion i'm talking about
without understanding the the
the fullness of from from which you've
come you can't really
fulfill your supreme moment of destiny
and i think everybody has a supreme
moment of destiny so what you've done
and what you've been doing
and actually people have several supreme
moments some people do
so i think being connected to that which
is greater than yourself
for me at this particular time in my
life is the most important thing and
that's what i'm i'm working on
um um one of the things i did in next
chapter
i went to visit a town called tm town
and it's in fairfield iowa would you
imagine that in fairfield iowa
uh to town population about 9 500 a
third of the town
meditates so there's a traffic jam
in fairfield iowa at 5 30
with mothers and doctors and dentists
and lawyers and engineers and clerks and
soccer moms
all headed to the dome in fairfield iowa
people who look just like you and me
and they're all there meditating and in
order to prepare for
doing that show um i brought the
transcendental meditations into harpo
studios
to teach me and my team how to meditate
so we started
meditating seven of us seven led to 70
led to 270
led to now everybody in the company
meditates 9 o'clock in the morning
4 30 in the afternoon no matter what's
going on we stop
we meditate and that way of being still
with ourselves coming back to
the center and recognizing that
something is more important than you
it's more important than
the work you're doing it's more
important brings a kind of energy and a
an an intensity of energy
an intention that we've never had before
and you you can't imagine what's
happened in the company
people who used to have migraines don't
people are sleeping better
people have better relationships people
interact with other people better it's
been fantastic
meditation is the biggest gift that i
can give anyone
and i would say more than anything it is
whatever reason for success i've had
uh because it allows one
on back to the two u's i'll clarify
what i mean is that in your mind
that we think what do you want and the
reality
is when you look at the neuroscience and
psychology
that there are different parts of your
brain that want different things
and so in the simplest sense there is
the
logical part of the brain that you're
conscious of it's called the conscious
and you think you're being logical and
you want to make those decisions
and then there's the subliminal below
the limbic system
part of the brain which is the emotional
and it's not as conscious to you but it
has more of an influence
on you than really the logical one and
so they're not aligned
and so when you're experiencing that
pain or let's say the ego right there
were two
main things you got an ego barrier and a
blind spot barrier
if you can get past your ego barrier and
you get past your blind spot barrier
you can accomplish anything because you
also know that you don't have to do
everything to you have to figure it out
yourself you can take in
from other people the different ways to
approach things in the best possible way
and so the realization that we all
are really struggling with ourselves and
to think
which are which is in control meditation
helps to deal with the alignment of
those two things
what happens what happens with
meditation as you know
um is it's just a simple exercise
that allows you first to clear your head
and then brings um
an equanimity to everything everything
it
eliminates the stress it eliminates the
emotion do it how often
um you're a busy guy yeah i i i've been
doing it for
uh 44 years but i do it you know
twice a day probably a third of the time
once a day
probably a third of the time and not at
all 20 minutes twice a day yeah
oh it's such a great investment i would
say that more than any
other factor uh having any effect on my
success
it's been meditation because the
equanimity uh and also the creativity
because it opens
uh between the literally the prefrontal
cortex
and the amygdala it opens the two sides
of the brains
and allows a spontaneity a creativity
an open-mindedness and and so it's good
for the not only the health because
because it you get with stress is a
terrible thing but it also is very good
in terms of the clarity and you don't
get the emotional hijacking
and it's great for creativity so it's
helped me a lot
it's the biggest gift i can give anyway
i do transcendental meditation there are
all sorts of different types of
meditation that i think
it has changed my life it has been so
powerful
and it's probably the biggest gift that
i can give anybody
uh because it gives you i'll describe it
i guess briefly
um it um it connects your
conscious mind with your subconscious
mind and gives you an equanimity
and a creativity that you ordinarily
wouldn't have
and the reason it does that
mechanistically the way it does it
is by um having a mantra
which is a word that mean doesn't have a
meaning it's a sound
something like uh you know popular one
would be om
you re repeat that with your breath and
that
means that you get rid of your thoughts
because you if you sit there and say
i'm going to try not to think you can't
do that your thoughts just jump around
and so to get rid of your thoughts you
go to this mantra you repeat it over and
over again
and your so when you pay attention to
that you can't be thinking about
something
and then eventually the mantra
disappears and you're in a subconscious
state
and when you're in that subconscious
state you're you're neither conscious or
unconscious you're in your subconscious
state and that's where
uh so it's relaxing and it's great and
it gives you that equanimity
but it also is where creativity comes
from because
um you know you don't you don't muscle
creativity you don't say i'm going to
work there
get creative it's more like relaxation
you're take a hot shower and this great
idea comes to you
so it bubbles up from your subconscious
and so
it enhances creativity and also i would
say one of the
best things that one can do is recogni
reconcile one's subconscious
emotional self with one's
intellectual self because if you can get
those things aligned like if they work
in both
ways you're going to make better
decisions so
meditation has given me that kind of
equanimity so i look at things
um i you know things i might not want to
happen but i can
approach them calmly and better
um so it's a big deal it's been a big
deal for me
1968 the beatles went to india
uh to learn how to meditate and and then
um i heard quite a bit about it and was
in the media
it was interesting and then i tried um
i learned how to meditate
[Music]
and it was it was definitely
life-changing
i would say that probably more than
anything
it had a bigger effect on my life than
practically anything
because of how it works and the way it
works is
it's it it's it's basically
open-mindedness that what happens is
normally uh you can't control your brain
if you were to sit down
and say i'm not going to think it will
be filled with stuff and it'll jump all
over
and you can't control it so what happens
is this is an exercise that creates
open-mindedness
because um there's a a word that doesn't
make sense which is called a mantra so
it's a sound
that you repeat and so while your brain
is
wanting to jump all over the place by
repeating this sound
mentally it takes your attention away
from those
thoughts and then by when you continue
to repeat it
it goes away and so there's nothing
and so you go into nothingness
okay now when you go into that
nothingness
first of all you've you've learned the
ability to control your brain
so that you can go there you can put
things away
you can approach them in a certain way
when you go into that that
open-mindedness
you're going into your subconscious so
you're not a state of conscious
so i'm not aware but i'm not asleep um
a sleep is you know when you hear a
sound you won't wake up
this is if i hear the slightest sound
i'm you know
attuned to it so it's a state of um
subconsciousness and and
there are different parts of our brain
that have a very big influence on us
the amygdala is the part of the brain
that has the
fight or flight that produces anxiety
the prefrontal cortex is the part of the
brain
which we call for executive functioning
or it's the part that's reflective
it's the part that um we
are calm and we say do we want to do
that do we not want to do that we put
things in perspective
those two parts of the brain are fight
for
with each other in other words the
passion i'm going to
do that because it's exciting but it may
be harmful the other part of the brain
says
you don't want to do that and so that
whole emotional fight-or-flight part of
the brain
during meditation through brain imaging
they see that that calms down
and the prefrontal cortex lights up
so um that open-mindedness
creates um where creativity comes from
because
creativity is not coming from the
working the brain and the i will
work hard and think about it and that i
will muscle it through
it comes from this relaxation it's just
like it's an opening up
and you know take a hot shower and don't
be thinking of something and some great
idea comes through and you grab the
great idea
so meditation is very much um like that
it opens it opens the mind creates an
openness
a freedom it's in which that i don't
know whether we would say intuition
or those that creativity just kind of
comes through
and it creates an equanimity that in
other words you could step back and you
can
put things in perspective it doesn't
lessen your emotions the motions are the
same but you can step back and say
i'm not going to be controlled by that
emotion or let me put things and i think
it then helps to see things at a higher
level
what is your strategy for dealing with
distractions
what is your strategy for dealing with
distractions
that's a great question yes
something that is
that you've heard about you've heard
about this
but it's that thing like are you willing
to go
to where you need to go and get out your
comfort zone
the number one thing that has been able
to help me with distractions is two
things
one of them is prayer just taking two
minutes
to quiet everything out and talk to god
and then the second thing which i was
like i can't do this like
i can't even believe i said that it's
meditation
meditation if if that's one thing you'll
take away which
which from today is just go on youtube
and say
10 minute meditation smooth music some
type in anything 10 minute meditation i
got to go see my girl she mad at me
you know what i'm saying like whatever
it is type it in
and and just just really kind of clear
your mind
most people let the outside world affect
them so they're not coming forth with
themselves
they're a reaction to somebody else's
action
when you get into things like meditation
a little bit or into yoga
you're more into yourself it's so
powerful
at a partner of mine that was in bad
shape
he had a heart problem at one of his
kidneys was missing already
and he could not qualify for the heart
transplant list he could not qualify
he was too bad if you're too bad you
don't qualify for too good it's like
right in the middle there right he
couldn't qualify but he was too bad for
him his body was really deteriorated
i called a friend of mine dr dean ornish
and dr dean orrish is a brilliant man
he has found out how to reverse heart
disease
different forms of cancer different
forms of
diabetes through diet and meditation the
thing is
you must have diet you must have
meditation
and you must have exercise combined
together within three months
this fellow not only got qualified for
the list
but got often at the top that fast in
three months
but it was diet meditation and of course
exercise
well when you're into yoga i believe
it's a combination of exercise
and meditation you're like trying to be
there with the one
and it's something that really works
what i do in the morning is i don't sit
around for an hour meditating but every
morning i'll get up
and i'll take at least five minutes and
just be look around the room the ceiling
whatever's in front of me and just be in
the present not think about my problems
not think about my goodness not think
about anything good or bad during the
day what i'm gonna do next
just try and be in the here and now
which is difficult to do
yeah and then i've just just a small
mantra that i do it's just one sentence
uh you know and that is creator souls
thank you for the life you've given me
help let me see the truth and you know
and share what i have and make the world
better off because i'm here
very short very very short repeat at one
time that said and
try and be in the here and now and i
probably do that 90 of the time
i started playing with meditation about
20 years ago it wasn't
that serious and i think the the the
most
i you know i actually practiced
within that time frame was you know
probably 20
30 minutes and wasn't
really aware of a lot of the theories
and um
some of the the focus that i needed
until
about two years ago when i went to my
first vimpasana course i went um
to this little town just south of
dallas and did a 10-day silent
meditation retreat
and it was one of the hardest but also
one of the most rewarding things i've
ever done
and one of the practices of impasana is
to
do one of these retreats every year but
also to carry through
with your practice you do two hours a
day one hour in the morning
uh one hour in the evening before before
bed and
the um i mean what it's what it's done
for me is
is really just a sense of clarity um
i certainly certainly want to focus um
certainly one of recognizing when i'm
reacting to something which uh has this
you know momentum of not feeling
necessarily in control
but as i did it
uh you know at the end of last year
i just went even deeper into that
clarity and was
you know instantly reminded of the year
prior
and uh you you i had this experience
where i just felt like i was picking up
where i
where i left off and that was really
powerful to me
so for me every single day it's a time
to
build self-awareness and that's what it
comes down to
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week also if you've already
got your billionaire mindset companion
pdf calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free in the first line of
the description below and if you're
enjoying this billionaire mindset series
give me a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
i never thought i'd do this meditation
creates a natural environment for the
body to heal itself
michael edwards michael said i needed to
do healing meditation
now i fully believe in the benefits of
meditation i believe the science
i believe the people who tell me it
works for them but it never worked for
me
i've tried following youtube videos
guided meditation apps and one-on-one
coaching with some of the best
meditation teachers
in the world but i never felt anything i
didn't feel any different coming out of
a meditation than going in i must have
tried 30 to 40 different techniques
from different people because i believe
that it works i just never found the
method that worked for me
and yet the thing that never worked for
me was the very thing my new advisor
promised would heal my
broken neck great i'm all in
tell me what to do he gave me specific
music to listen to
specific visualizations to do while
meditating specific instructions on how
to
position myself specific instructions on
timing and frequency
he followed up with me regularly and
kept sending his support belief and
guidance
when i loaded my messages his was the
first one i went to because
at this moment in my life he was one of
the most important people around me i
did the meditations because i believed
in michael
and i believed in michael because he
told his story again it comes back to
his story
his journey got my attention it got me
to do something that i had never had
success with
i stuck with it i did a morning and
evening meditation
every day exactly like michael had
instructed me to do i didn't miss a
single day
what was a nice to have luxury suddenly
became a top priority
because i needed to get rid of this
concussion from my broken neck then
i started to heal within a couple days i
started feeling better
i still had a lot of brain fog but i
could start to think again
one week later i was able to lead a
workshop for an hour and a half
another week later i could lead my full
three hour workshop
two more weeks and i stopped getting
dizzy when i lay down the broken bone in
my neck
also healed was it because of my
meditation or just no more healing
i honestly don't know but i was
dedicated to my meditation because i
wanted to heal like michael had
he told his story and it impacted me now
it's time for you
to tell yours
holosync is a tool it's just a
meditative tool that
basically entrains your brain there's a
lot of different tools that you can use
there's a lot of different types of
meditations
and and so some people prefer meditating
without
the aid of a tool some people prefer to
use a tool so there's
a variety of different tools that people
could use and we can talk about
you know which ones they are which ones
work for different people and why
so let's start with what is your daily
meditation practice
okay so for example it's eight o'clock
in the morning here in san diego right
now
about two hours ago when i woke up um
the first thing that i do after i pee
is i go sit on my sofa looking at the
ocean
and this morning for example i was just
doing a
very quiet breathing meditation
listening to sound bowls
so i bought some audios on the internet
somewhere
uh somebody had some really good sound
bowls where you know they're
they're they're hitting the sound bowls
or rotating
uh a little piece of um wood around the
sound bowl
and i just focus on releasing any of my
own
thoughts i focus on concentrating and
and listening just to the waves that the
sound bowls create
so in doing that what actually is
happening
is i'm learning that i could be still
i'm learning that i could be aware of my
thoughts but then let them go and i come
back to focus
on a sound wave in this particular
meditation
and then what happens is over a period
of practice
you realize that you're basically your
body disappears
you're no longer in this physical thing
you're no longer having these
waves of thought after thought after
thought after thought after thought
after idea positive negative and
everything in between
and in that space of recognizing that
i'm not my physical body i have a
physical body i'm not my thoughts i have
thoughts i'm not my emotions i have them
when you start to train yourself to use
your brain
better more efficiently more
productively
you realize that a i am one with
this you know incredible universe so
what's the big deal about that
well the big deal is that if i am one
with this
universe with this energy with everyone
and everything
and that's where everything percolates
from
is it possible that all my answers are
right here right now anyway
and the answer is yeah and so meditation
is about practicing and we know that we
have
uh different brain waves so right now as
people are watching or listening
you know they're in this beta brainwave
frequency where their
brain is oscillating at a certain
frequency and there's 50 different brain
waves going on at any given time
but what happens is when i move into
from beta to alpha to
theta delta or gamma i'm actually
accessing and activating different parts
of my brain which now gives me
this deeper greater sense of awareness
of a much bigger you know onion
that i'm used to seeing so i'm living on
a layer of an onion
and what if i could see like 10 layers
up and 10 layers down
all of a sudden it's like wow look at
who i am
what i am who you are what you are and
in that realization in that awareness
i can now start to have different
choice choices made and so meditation
is a practice of awareness it's a
practice of going
internal instead of external which is
where most people live their lives every
day we can have meditative states while
we're watching a movie we can have
meditative trans like states while we're
reading a book
we can have a meditative statement we're
looking to each other's eyes
and we're so in love that we just lose
ourselves and oh my god where did the
time go it's been five or six hours
that you know we've been transfixed on
each other we can have a meditative
state sitting quietly
not even breathing that our skin is
breathing
so all of these meditative states
mindfulness states are geared towards
giving us a much greater understanding
and awareness of connectedness of
source uh that we all emanate from
and the question is like why would you
want to do that
and the answer is in the world that we
live in right now
it is non-stop stimuli
nonstop distraction texts emails
instagram facebook twitter pinterest
youtube
all of the things people like you and me
looking to have our audiences come
learn with us that we we can teach and
share you know everybody's being
distracted
well what we do know is you know i keep
this magnifying glass
right here on my desk and this is to
remind me
that you know the sun is you know a
ball of nuclear fusion and energy
and it heats up a general area and you
get a nice little tan if you stay in the
sun
long enough well if i take a magnifying
glass i could take that same sun
and i could take you know this sheet of
paper right and if i can get the
magnifying glass and the sheet of paper
lined up
i could burn this piece of paper by
focusing the energy
well i could take that same energy of
the sun
that can magnify through a magnifying
glass but now if i can
focus it to a single photon that's known
as a laser i can cut through steel
well is it possible that yours in my
brain the most powerful electromagnetic
switching station or tool in the
universe that's taking light that's
coming in through our eyes
sound that's coming in through our ears
is it possible that we can train
ourselves
to focus so intently on our vision
on our goal on releasing what doesn't
serve us on starting what will help us
achieve our goals better
is it possible that meditation
and or mindfulness allows us to focus
our brains energy on a vision and goal
and outcomes so intently
that we are resonating and oscillating
100 trillion cells of our body because
of our focus of our brain
and we are in alignment and resonance or
in harmony
with what it is that we want to achieve
do
be or have and the answer is yes because
everything in the universe is made up of
energy including
my body including you know this
magnifying glass including my pen
so the very art of learning how to
use my brain the greatest organism in
the
known universe it's an organism that we
can manipulate
and use better now allows me
no differently than you know i can take
a radio or my cell phone right i can
turn the dial and tune into a different
station
uh 95.1 is rock and roll 95.5
is uh classical music 95.8
is punk rock if we learn
or when we learn to use our brain
better more efficiently more precisely
to tune into what it is that we want
is it possible that that is using the
law of attraction or resonance or
harmony the way we're supposed to be
using it
so that we can achieve more of the goals
and dreams we have but in a diffused
fractured state
okay we're not able to use our brains as
well so meditation
gives you the ability to focus your
intention
and attention on the outcomes that you
want versus what you don't want
when you sit down to meditate do you
come with an intention then each time no
i i i
when once i sit down then i ask
my intuition hey uh what is it
that you want to be doing today what is
it that you need today
so we all have this intuition which is
different than our
instinct but this intuition right it's
what we know before we think
and so when i sit down and say okay
um hey uh what's what's the intention
for today
and sometimes the intention is to just
let go and see what happens
sometimes the intention is i'm searching
for you know for an
answer uh sometimes the intention is
well today focus
you know today let go today just breathe
so i just listen i just it's jus it's
it's the
the art and the subtle science of paying
attention and i have a philosophy that
every moment every precious nanosecond
and moment is
perfect and so when i connect to the
perfection of that
moment there's really nothing to do
it's to be aware and to allow to
surrender
but not to give up surrender but to
understand that
you know as you know we are talking
right now
uh the oceans don't need any instruction
what to do the uh the um planets that
are
moving in in their elliptical orbits
around the sun
don't need yours or my intervention the
universe the milky way galaxy that's you
know flowing through the universe at a
million and a half miles per hour
doesn't need yours and my instruction so
that means that
every moment is perfect so i want to
connect to the perfection
of every single moment be aware of that
every single moment
and realize that many things are not to
my taste many things i don't understand
but that doesn't mean that the moment
isn't perfect
and so then can i direct a little bit of
this you know physical body can i direct
my mind can i manage my emotions well
enough
to make sure that what i do um has
purpose what i do has
meaning what i do brings value what i do
uh brings me
joy what i do brings me happiness and
the answer is of course and that's where
uh you know i share a lot you know in in
my book uh innercise
is awareness is what gives you choice
and it's
choice that gives you freedom and so
in choice we're no longer victims in
choice
okay we can become victorious and
everybody who's watching wants to become
victorious on their lives right
and so what if all we had to do is
pay attention remember the perfection
that you are remember the genius that
you are remember that
you can achieve whatever it is you
choose to achieve
now let's learn the art of focus let's
lineart of concentration let's learn the
art of letting go and surrendering
you know and priscilla is right all is
perfect in this precious moment or
present moment
okay can you share something that maybe
this week
came to you in a meditation that you
weren't even thinking about otherwise
and you acted on
um i i just got back from skiing in
in utah and um
one of the uh one of my passions is to
is to do some skiing where i
hike up and ski down these steeper
terrains which
i've been petrified of doing because
i've been hurt once before doing that
and so um this this ski run that we were
just at all to which
for the first time i was hiking up i was
panting like a dog
going up you know to 11 000 feet
elevation
and um at the top of the hill i just
said okay
let me enter into a meditative state i'm
58 years old
uh i've skated for you know 35 years uh
every moment of skiing the the stuff
i've done well the stuff that
you know that i've learned through some
of the failures of skiing i'm bringing
to this moment
right now so i did a little meditation
at the top of the ski hill i just closed
my eyes
and i just did some breathing exercises
just to connect you know to to
myself my emotions the present moment
remembering that every moment is perfect
that i'm skilled enough to be able to
to do this and i went
i just went and i trusted that
this moment was perfect or i wouldn't be
there so this was my opportunity to take
the lessons and to practice
in this moment and i had one of the best
ski runs of my life in a meditative
state
and it happened so fast thank god my
friends were down the hill videotaping
where i could actually see it and i was
like oh my god that's like one of my
best ski runs
ever and the reason for that is is
i went into this calm relaxed responsive
state versus a
fearful reactive state by going into a
meditative
awareness mindfulness state of the
moment and
and so that was a perfect opportunity
for me to go wow
you know it wasn't just that moment but
it was the 50 you know
35 years of skiing you know that came to
that moment
and and so that's a meditative state
where i was one with the mountain with
everything else
and um it may sound esoterical may sound
crazy but
you know all we have which everybody
talks about
is this this moment this this precious
second right now so the more i could be
here right now um
the more i'm living you know my uh the
life that i want to live
i don't want to be focusing too much
about the future too much about
the past i can use those as something to
you know hope for in the future
as a guiding post from the past um but
right now is the moment that
every one of us has i love it now i
broke my neck in two spots last during
my tour
and one of them healed and the other
part there's actually a piece of my neck
that
broke off that's still there that they
don't want to operate on
do you think there's a station i love it
i want to know what the frankenstein was
on the other side i like it yes
well that's what i wanted to show you
there's einstein which represents our
left prefrontal cort
cortex the the smart genius
part of our brain that has imagination
that can come up with all the ideas of
what about this what about this i can
have this i can have this
but what most people don't understand is
we also have right a frankenstein part
of our brain
the inner critic you know it says but
you're not good enough you're not smart
enough what if you fail what if you're
embarrassed what if you're ashamed
so we have this you know that's why i
have them there's einstein
and there's frankenstein just to remind
me and to remind my students
that both exist within us and
our goal is to understand that you know
the way our brain works is there's
always a protective side of our brain
so frankenstein's always going what if
you fail what if you succeed and fail
what if you disappoint yourself and
einstein's going
don't worry about it imagine the future
and so there's this constant battle in
our brains
you know going on in our goal and
meditation is one of the best ways to
recognize that both exist
and both are right your frankenstein
part of your brain is there to protect
you
your einstein brain is is ready to help
you achieve your goals and dreams
and the key is to remember you're not
your brain you're not the einstein part
you're not the frankenstein part
there's another side of you that is much
greater than
all of it and that's what meditation
helps you remember
that i have a brain i have the einstein
the frankenstein
and the ugly side of myself and the
nasty side of myself and the beautiful
side of myself
the loving side of myself and the
critical side of myself
all of that is a part of who every one
of
us is and when i start to realize that
and i say okay
now i can choose do i focus on
you know einstein and create what
i want or do i focus on frankenstein
and destruct which one do i want
so anyway a little bit of fun i like it
so
so do you think i can heal my broken
neck
with meditation when when doctors say
it's not going to connect
do you think i can manifest that
connection happening with that bone that
broke up
yes so why do i say that
well um we have 100 trillion cells in
our body
um i've had neck injuries shoulder
injuries meniscus injuries i've had
ankle injuries
i've had i've had injuries because i've
always been pretty athletic
um if you think about what is happening
every time i breathe in
i'm breathing in hydrogen oxygen
nitrogen carbon plus a whole bunch of
other elements from the air um what do
you think your bones and tissues and
muscles are made of i'm eating
you know let's say i'm eating a protein
whether it's tofu or
a piece of chicken right i'm eating a
protein that
is making muscle i'm eating fat i'm
drinking
water uh we are made up of hydrogen
oxygen nitrogen and carbon
mostly and so every seven years we're
making a
whole new body our eyeballs are
different our skeleton is different our
brain is not the same cells that were
in our brain seven years ago our lungs
liver heart
tissues nothing is the same
and so if i am visualizing if i am
meditating if i am seeing a new healed
bone if i'm seeing a new healed part of
my being
is it possible that i can direct
some of what's happening in my body the
answer is of course i can there are
so many people that have healed okay
from
traumatic brain injuries from back
injuries from
um from tears and all that stuff and so
i
absolutely believe that we can heal so
that is
that is my opinion and we're we're just
starting to scratch the proverbial
surface of what our
potential really is and it starts with
our brain
so what should my next step be i've got
this piece of bone floating around my
neck
i want to connect it what should my
daily practice be
well the question you know that i would
be asking number one is
is is connecting it what you want to be
doing right
um is it possible to release it
and then regrow some bone deliberately
okay right so so i would be looking at
first i would be doing a whole bunch of
research of who has actually done what i
want to do
right so is there one person on earth
that has recovered from the type of
trauma that i have
so i would look at the science first and
maybe the
metaphysics behind it i would be
visualizing
every single day my neck healed
so i'll give you an example maybe i can
put this into perspective for some
some of you when i was 22 years old
i was diagnosed with severe ulcerative
colitis
right i think avenue and i talked about
this before and severe ulcerative
colitis is
when your colon is inflamed it does this
but i had
ulcers in my colon it was bleeding and i
had zero bowel control movement
uh i if i had to go to the bathroom he's
like run and sometimes i would just [ __ ]
right in my pants
it doesn't make a difference who was
around where i was in a restaurant in
bed having sex
um in my car made no difference if i had
to go
it was like done and i
watched the tv show on psychoneuro
immunology the mind
body connection and at the time i was 22
years old
trying to work trying to make make money
and i wanted to figure out what was
causing my ulcer rate of colitis because
the ulcer rate of colitis was an effect
right so i was like what was causing it
and what i realized was causing it was a
lot of stress
the wrong foods too much alcohol no
exercise etc
so i said okay well how could i heal
myself and at the time i was taking
25 pills a day i was doing enemas in the
morning
enemas at night and going to the
hospital once a month for them to stick
a tube in my rectum to see what was
happening in my colon
not fun at 22 years old it's like what
the
front door right and so i said okay let
me see if i could really
heal myself and so i wrote an
affirmation i wish i had it here because
i'd read you it says my body and all its
organs were created by the infinite
intelligence in my subconscious mind
it created all my bones tissues muscles
uh liver lungs heart
and everything else within me it knows
how to heal me i am now perfectly
healthy that's a
short version of that and every day in
addition to eating well
exercising sleeping well i would read
this affirmation
i would close my eyes i would see my
colon healed
i would see my colon sick i'd see my
colon heal i'd see my colon six
sick i'd see my colon healed that's
called mental contrasting
in the world of neuroscience and so i
would see this
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over in my brain i would read it i would
feel it i would see it
five weeks of doing this after two and a
half
years of being sick
all of my symptoms went away a hundred
percent when i went in
to see my doctor his name was dr wu he
said to me
you've had a spontaneous remission i
said it's not
a spontaneous remission it was a
deliberate remission
that was 36 years ago
all right and the doctor says whatever
you're doing you know keep doing he says
but i want you to still take the pills i
was taking 25 pills a day
i said to him i said dr wu you don't
understand do you
i said i fixed the cause you still
want to treat the symptom
right and so i have shown
people how to get off of colitis crohn's
disease diverticulitis
our body is consistently re-manifesting
itself
based on our thoughts emotions feeling
sensations
and behaviors so what if
everyone watching what if i could be in
a vibration mentally
heart wise right emotionally and gut
wise so heart
brain heart and gut what if i can create
alignment
so that i am in a state of health so my
body is regenerating
healthy cells my body is regenerating
you know
or activating energy from my
mitochondria
what if i could be in this alignment
with
the flow of health versus a flow of dis
ease so for you
you know what happens with most people
is they're focusing on their dis
ease or their pain instead of channeling
their attention and energy
and focusing on health and well-being
so the more you say you know my neck is
broken my neck is broken i got a little
thing on my neck it's painful my neck
the doctors say i can't
this is impossible the more you keep
reinforcing the cellular activity
that reinforces that so there's the
difference between
um between um sticking your head in the
sand and pretending that the symptom
isn't there and what you focus on
so the symptom is there but the symptom
okay
is there because of something that
happened in the past if i keep
recreating what happened in the past
i just keep recreating at the cellular
structure
the continuity of that we're saying yes
what i have right now is because of the
past i accept that
and now i'm focusing on being 100
healthy
big big difference now we're not lying
to ourselves which i don't believe we
should do
right and by the way somebody um
somebody asked in here and by the way if
you're if you're all enjoying this
hit the like or the love button for me
and evan so we know you're
you're enjoying this i want to share one
one critical piece here
um somebody asked earlier you know you
know
can you do this for drug addiction a lot
of people don't know this but i used to
be addicted to alcohol
i haven't had a drink in over 10 years
and i haven't had
alcohol in 11 and a half out of 13 years
when i was going through a really
challenging time in my life through a
business partnership breakup with one of
my best friends
i would drink a bottle of wine a night
and i realized oh my god
i am hiding my emotions i'm getting
addicted to
alcohol as a way to deal with these
emotions i i want to suppress
and i use the exact same process to
stop drinking i've used the exact same
process to stop eating sugar because i
was addicted to sugar
i use the exact same process most of you
don't know this
i wish i had a picture but i was 243
pounds
10 years ago i'm 195 pounds a day i've
lost 43 pounds of fat
i've kept it off for 10 years why
because i'm focusing on the
inner game the power within you and me
is so
great that when we learn how to
focus our attention when we learn some
techniques to use our brain better
then we're empowered we are able to
really become
everything we are meant to become which
is what every one of us wants
we want to know you know am i okay you
know do you love me do i
do i love myself uh how do i have
purpose and meaning and that's really
what we all want we want this connection
but we also want to know that
our lives matter and that we're going to
be okay and i can tell everybody you're
going to be okay
maybe you just need to tweak a little
bit of what you're doing what brings me
to a place of strength and
peace is
i don't believe the lies
of the mind every every thought you have
is a magical lie it's an interpretation
of a perceptual experience which is
radically untrue so for example
my perception tells me the earth is flat
nobody believes that anymore
my perception tells me that the ground
i'm sitting on is stationary and i know
it's spinning at dizzying speeds
and hurting through space at thousands
of miles an hour my
perception tells me that i'm looking at
your body
but actually i'm not it's a perceptual
activity in myself
so a while ago i decided not to believe
my mind and what i do is step back
from the mind and watch it
and i notice that there's me
watching it and what is me watching it
it's watching the
party it's watching my thoughts he's
watching you it's watching everything
else so stand in front of a mirror
and the mirror reflects everything not
just you but everything else is
happening
and if you understand that the entire
world is a mirror
of you filtered through the crazy mind
then you don't depend on the mind you
depend on the awareness of the mind
so when i see a situation whatever it is
good bad
word whatever i ask myself who's
watching
and then i pay attention to the watcher
and i stay there and it's profoundly
peaceful and joyful at all times
how do we make that an intentional
practice
so that we don't have our instant
reaction to freak out or stress out or
how do we go from making it that instant
reaction to an intentional practice
well a lot of people say you know i want
to quiet in my mind
and then they struggle in meditation but
trying to
quieten the mind is a thought so it's
also the mind so you can't use the mind
to quiet
the mind right all you have to do is ask
yourself
what am i aware of right now and then
favor
the awareness instead of the experience
because the experience is a projection
of the mind awareness is independent
awareness
is infinite possibilities it's
limitless it's beyond imagination it's
infinite it's the real you that recycles
as body mind
people talk about reincarnation but
reincarnation is happening
every second every thought that you have
is reincarnated thought
every perception that you have is
actually a recycled perception
we just get bamboozled as soon as we're
given a name so you know i was given the
name deepak
chopra now that is a symbol
of who i am it's not who i am but
you know if you repeat somebody's name
enough you're david you're david you're
david
then the poor kid is crude because he
thinks he's david
when in fact he's the infinite being
with the name called david
so you know you're not your name your
name is a symbol of who you are
if i'm looking at a menu in a book
and all these beautiful dishes are there
i can't eat the menu
okay so we use words as
symbols and of course you know spiritual
literature says
first there was the word the word was
with god and god
you know became the word or whatever
there's some truth in that
as soon as you use words
you create form so if i ask you what is
this you say it's a book
but actually it's a color it's a shape
it's a form if a baby was looking at
this book it would be
squiggles shapes forms and colors
no idea that this is a book and the baby
is called david no idea
it's a joyful experience because the
baby would see this and everything else
as
itself and would fall in fact is in love
with existence all you have to look at
is a
baby the only time it says is when it's
hungry
or it's wet otherwise it's in bliss
and why is it in bliss because it hasn't
been bamboozled
by constructs i come from a tradition by
the way
wisdom traditions where there's a thing
called mahasamadhi
maha means big samadhi means the big
meditation
when you choose you say okay
been there done that i had a great life
my father
did that by the way my father was a
cardiologist
and trained in england so at the end of
his life he said i had a great innings
and you know he used to play cricket so
i had a great innings it's over
so i'm going to say goodbye and then he
closed his eyes
and you know he actually went to the
room where my mother was sleeping
said goodbye to her went back to his
room sat in bed closed his eyes and he
was gone
now yeah he probably had a cardiac
arrhythmia or something there has to be
something that causes the final
um exit right but as far as i'm
concerned he died in peace
and in contentment and
without fear that is called mahasamadhi
it's a tradition
amongst my gurus going back thousands of
years
and so of course they don't talk about
it
they're you know they don't they don't
care what the world thinks of them
they're not on twitter or
instagram or doing youtube videos
they're happy and you know i
get that i get that i'm 74 right now
my blood pressure is 110 over 70 my
cholesterol is younger than
better than anybody who's 40 years of
age my heart rate variability says i
have no stress
i enjoy every day a joyful energetic
body
love and compassion in my heart clear
mind
and lightness of being if you have those
four things there's nothing else you
want
everything else is like crumbs you know
like what do you call it dessert a
little bit
cherry on the on the top of the cake the
reality
is joy at all times even if you sat
down quietly closed your eyes
observed your breath and took an
inhalation
to the counter
pause to the count of two exhale to the
count of six
your breathing rate will come down from
14 to about eight
if you do that for a minute just one
minute
if you go a little bit beyond that once
you get comfortable with that you
increase it so breathe in to six
positive breathe out six
your brain waves will go from beta
to alpha alpha is a vegetative state
but if you actually become good at this
i can take my brain waves down to
theta which is the dream state and then
if i want i can actually take it down
to four the breathing rate with practice
slowly but comfortably that
takes you to delta which is depressed
the equivalent
of deep sleep okay and you're still
awake of course but you're rested
the equivalent of deep sleep for that
one minute so i would say take a
breathing break
or just ask yourself am i aware and then
shift from
the thought to the awareness in which
that thought is
happening and notice that awareness
and hang in there and you'll be fine
immediately i love it here's another
thing yeah i call it the stop formula
stop s stands for stop
t take three deep breaths and smile from
your head to your toe everywhere
your fingernails your eyes your nose
your mouth your heart
even your genitalia are smiling and then
um
observe your body feel it
and then choose the response you want at
that moment
or you can even make it simpler press
the pause button
pause breathe and choose
in looking at your work over the past
number of decades you've really
been at the front of helping make
meditation
an everyday thing i mean in the 80s
nobody knew about meditation and now
everybody knows what meditation is me
personally i think
meditation has helped a lot with just
mindfulness and presence where i
struggle with it and maybe you've got
some insider guidance on this is
get into an altered state where it feels
like
hey i've been doing meditation for two
hours but it only feels like five
minutes
if i sit down for an hour i'm present
i'm mindful i'm focused but it still
feels like an hour
where am i on the meditation journey
that i need to like make the next
breakthrough
even if it feels like an hour if there
are
moments when you lose track of time you
say oh
where was i you were
infinite at that moment so don't
try and count the time
that you left the arena
or the theater of space time and
causality
the easier you are the more spontaneous
it'll be
not in meditation you know when somebody
is having a good time what did they say
i lost track of time when somebody falls
in love
there's no time right when you fall in
love with anything
even an idea time goes you fall in love
with the person with the baby
for that moment when you are feeling
that experience
there's no time okay so that's our
essential
nature when we are connected with all
that
is so when people say i get
i meditate to get away to plug unplug
it's actually inaccurate you get
meditate to pluck
you don't get meditated to
get away from it all you get in touch
with it all
when solitude is not the same thing as
loneliness loneliness comes from the
fear
of the ego itself solitude is being
connected to all that exists
so just make that distinction okay and
you'll see
when you're listening to music do you
think when is this going to end
okay you're listening to a song do you
ask yourself when
is the song going to end or you're
dancing or watching a ballerina
do you does she think when am i going to
finish
right no because they are in love
and they've become what they're doing so
it is never a problem never a problem
to focus or
concentrate as the word is i don't like
the word concentrate it gives me a
headache just thinking about it
but it is never a problem to focus
on something if you love it
right okay so only do the things that
you love can you explain
the cover of this book so this came in
at first it
it was beautifully wrapped i almost
didn't want to open it
because it was so beautifully packaged
and put together but but i had to so i
can get through it for this interview
what is the symbolism here what does
this mean to you why did you pick this
design for the cover
this is a a mural in one of our
meditation halls in the east yoga center
in india
this is uh some people say this is the
largest mural in the world i don't know
for sure but some people claim it is the
largest one
so we designed this mural to depict
the five dimensions upon which a human
being can work
when i say five dimensions see the
entire physical world
is made up of five elements in the yogic
senses
uh water earth water fire
air and space these are the five
these five dimensions only with these
five the entire
entire universe is made so is your body
so the fundamental of yogic sciences is
in this which is called as bhuta
that means one thing is to cleanse the
elements in your system
another thing is to have mastery or
these elements
if you have mastery over the elements
within your system
then your body your mind your energies
everything functions the way you want so
you don't do anything about it
because you're not taking care of the
ingredients the final cooking
is a mess so the yoga the basis the
foundational practices of yoga are
called as bhuta
well when i say yoga in north america
well it means something else
that's not what i'm talking about when
we say yogic sciences
the most basic of these practices are
buddhisti
so this is a depiction of buddha shuddhi
working with
earth working with water working with
air
working with fire and space so this is
working with air
this imagery of a yogi hanging upside
down from a tree
and working upon the air in the system
when i say air in the system right now
everybody understands particularly with
the pandemic everybody understands how
important it is to breathe properly
so it's not just about the breath every
cell in the body has a certain amount of
air
in it invested so generally
we see that about 70 to 72 percent is
water
about 12 is earth about six to eight
percent
is air the remaining part is fire and
space
so this six to eight percent of air has
a significant role to play in our life
the way you think and the way you
breathe are very
directly connected today modern science
also is acknowledging this
that uh you know suppose you this is
something that we do
in the yogic system that if you simply
sit here and think about mountains
if you check your breath it'll be one
way you think about a tiger
it'll be another way you think about
ocean it'll be another way because
your thought and your breath are so
directly connected
well at least this everybody knows if
they become
if their thoughts become little fearful
you know their breath
goes into a certain state of
exaggeration or
aberration will happen so breath and
thought process is very directly
connected
right now what people call as happiness
and unhappiness is essentially
in your thoughts if what you want is
happening you are happy
in your thoughts what you don't want is
happening you're unhappy
so in this way for your happiness
to live happily and peacefully here the
most fundamental thing is
your breath should happen in such a way
naturally your chemistry will function
in such a way
that your thought process will be the
way you want it
this is as simple as that if your
thought and emotion happen the way you
want well you will be joyful there's no
question about
it the life around you the world around
you may not happen the way you want
always
especially right now it doesn't happen
but
your thought and your emotion is
happening your way you're joyful by your
nature
so in that context air or mastery over
air
in the system is very important if you
want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there